welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to thinking
like a billionaire now you can just
watch this video or if you want to sign
up for the entire series for
free and get the bonus pdf companion
calendar
check the link in the description below
today is day 26 and we're gonna learn
how billionaires overcome their
failures enjoy
[Music]
you've also said that failure was the
most likely outcome can you talk about
failure in that sense and
in a broader sense of being an
entrepreneur and an innovator
why is failure so important
uh well i mean i think i think failure
is bad
i don't think it's good but if if
if something's important enough then you
you do it even though the risk of
failure is high
um and and so i think my advice if
somebody
is wants to start a company is they
should bear in mind that the most likely
outcome
is is that it's not going to work and
they should reconcile themselves to that
past strong possibility and they should
only do it if they feel that they
they're they're really compelled to do
it you know um
because it's it's it's gonna the way
starting company works is like
usually in the beginning it's the very
beginning it's kind of fun um
and then it's really hellish for for a
number of years
you talked about chewing glass yeah
there's
there's a friend of mine who's a
successful entrepreneur um and uh
started actually his career around the
same time as i did and he has a good
good good phrase his name's bully he
said yeah
you're starting companies like eating
glass and staring into the abyss
and and you agree with that generally
true
um yeah and and and if you don't eat the
glass you're not going to be successful
when trying different things you you've
got to have some acceptance of failure
as you're alluding to earlier failure
must be an option if failure is not an
option it's going to result in extremely
conservative choices
and you may not may get something even
worse than
lack of innovation things may go
backwards
um so um if
what you really want is uh
to be proportionate to the actions that
you seek
so if uh if what you're seeking is
innovation
then you should reward success and
innovation
um and only
there should be minor consequences for
lack of
minor consequences for for trying and
failing
there should be minor with significant
rewards for trying and succeeding
minor consequences for trying and not
succeeding
and big and major negative consequences
for not
trying i always thought we would fail so
this is
all it's all upside down you know i
thought maybe we had a 10 chance of
reaching orbit starting out so
then uh if people thought
when we started spacex they said oh
you're going to fail
so i agree i think we probably will fail
yeah it's worth trying anyway yeah
yeah how's that for honesty huh yeah
this let's
like you know lose all the money from
paypal i was like well you're probably
right
you know and we're almost there we first
three launches the falcon one didn't
work and the fourth one we scraped
together some parts and
then that one worked and if that one
hadn't worked it would have been that
would have been it for us
so um i really believe in the future of
space and
and i think it's important that we
become a space faring civilization
and and not be out there among the stars
and i think that's one of the things
that
you know makes people excited about the
future and
we want the things that are in science
fiction novels and
movies not to be science fiction forever
we want them to be real one day
by the way getting it wrong isn't that
bad that's the other thing
when when when we make mistakes and
we've made doozies like the fire phone
and many other things that just didn't
work out i can i could
we don't have enough time for me to list
all of our failed experiments
but the big winners pay for thousands of
failed experiments so you try something
like prime
and it was very expensive at the
beginning it cost us a lot of money
because what happens when you offer a
free
all you can eat buffet who shows up to
the buffet first
the heavy eaters scary
it's like oh my god did i really say as
many prawns as you can eat
and um and so that is what happened but
sure but surely we could see the trend
lines we could see that you know
the dif all kinds of customers were
coming and they appreciated that service
one of them is you have to have a
willingness to fail
you have to have a willingness to be
misunderstood for long periods of time
if you do something in a new way and i
don't care
what it is people are initially
going to misunderstand it relative to
the traditional way
and they will they'll be well-meaning
critics
who you know genuinely want the best
outcome but they're worried about this
new way
and they'll also be of course
self-interested critics
who have a vested interest in the
traditional they have some profit stream
tied to the traditional way
um but but doing things and if you want
to if you never want to be criticized
for goodness sake don't do anything new
so
it's it's it's okay though if you have a
willingness to be misunderstood for long
periods of time
if you have a willingness to fail then
what you can do is you can ramp up your
rate of experimentation
so successful invention successful
invention is inventions that customers
care
about it's actually relatively easy to
invent new things that customers don't
care about
but successful invention
if you want to do a lot of that you
basically have to increase your rate of
experimentation
and that you can think of as a process
how do you go about
organizing your systems
your people
all of your assets your own daily life
and how you spend time how do you
organize those things to increase your
rate of experimentation
because not all of your experiments are
going to work i found
something really interesting is that
people that have typically gone to
really good
schools and done really well grade wise
they're used to getting a's on
everything
have a much harder time taking risk
because they just
they look at something that has a low
probability of success
and say well why would i do that i don't
i'm out you know i'm used to getting a's
and that's 95 percent
so why would i do something that's 20
well because the outcome is 200x or 500x
that's why you do it
but a lot of people just can't get
comfortable with that i think that's
different between an entrepreneur or not
somebody who's comfortable
with a low probability of success with a
huge outcome and then you'd go after it
and you're okay failing i failed
so many times as a kid whether it be
academically or otherwise
that i was so comfortable with failing
that it was not even a constant you know
it just meant
that combined with just being chill
generally about
things not working out the combination
of that allowed me to like
freely just take risks without any
regard for
for like maybe failing i love the story
that you have about applying to college
and the non-zero probability i thought
that was really
really a powerful story walk us through
that okay yeah so
uh you know i didn't have good grades in
in high school i really didn't
i it was this is funny i tell people
this nobody believes the story but it
was sophomore year in high school
i remember walking down sort of the
corridor and somebody's like hey
where where are you going to go to
college or what are you thinking about
i said oh i'm probably just going to go
to harvard and they said harvard
like you you can't you're not going to
get in harvard
and i was like what do you what do you
mean don't you just
like kind of send your thing in and pay
and go like no you have to actually
apply and they have to accept you
that was sophomore year in high schools
when i learned that which is crazy these
days because i've been talking to my
daughters since they were like you know
this year big about college so but yeah
so i didn't really know so i didn't i
wasn't applying myself in school
didn't have good grades and my dad
um had asked me this is i did all the
applying myself went to the colleges
myself
parents didn't know what was going on
and then after the deadline this is like
in
january february the deadline was like
you know november december
applying to college and my dad said hey
uh um
how's it going how's the college stuff
coming you know where are you going to
apply i said oh i already did i replied
i'm done he's like oh
you applied already what did did you
apply to wharton
because he knew that i knew that that
was i talked about that business school
and i wanted to do business and stuff
like oh no i didn't i didn't apply to
wharton um there's no way i could have
gotten in
and he said oh really there's no way you
could have gotten in
zero it's zero and i said well
i don't know if it's zero it's pretty
close to zero though and i said there's
a lot of essays and all this stuff he's
like oh so
so it's work you you didn't want to do
the work i said no i'm fine to do the
work it's just
it's basically my guidance counsel told
me i can't get in
objectively i don't think i can get in
so you know i didn't apply
he's like all right he was looking at me
and i'm like
all right you're right dad i'm going to
apply you know and
uh and this was after the deadline so
this is like two months later
i went did all the essays did the whole
application did everything sent it in
i never forget it was like may when you
sort of got the letter i went out to the
mailbox i saw it it said you know what
in school
i ran in i opened it up yeah i got
rejected
um but but it really taught me a great
lesson because
when i was opening that envelope it
really felt non-zero to me
even though it was like i had no chance
of getting in and it was after the fact
you know and it probably was as close to
zero as anything could possibly get but
i just
felt like happy that i went through the
process
nothing had changed it was still the
same probability but i was really happy
i went through the process and took a
shot
and i was actually i had it at bat that
letter that chance that it could
there's a possibility it could have it
could have said accepted
although it's as close to you and so
i've just taken that in life in general
it's like just i'm not going to accept
that it can't be done unless somebody
proves it's a zero probability and often
the case
you can't prove it's zero there's always
some non-zero probability
and it's typically the stuff that has
that's really close to non-zero
nobody else is touching that's where the
big opportunities are who you are
when you find yourself under stress and
anxiety things go wrong
you get disappointments uh things don't
work out as you hoped
you must feel uh a moment of anxiety a
moment of stress
how do you deal with that what happens
um
i can go out of the stress
i can at any moment like there are times
where
i feel the stress of the circumstances
and then i can at will
go out of that stress and just
see things in a different way and it
makes me feel
um almost like a ninja you know when the
in the ninja everything seems to come in
slow motion
you know and in the sense you could step
back and it's coming at me
at slow motion and i can deal with it in
in a way that makes me
feel more centered and in control but
like tennis players they say
at the height of their game the ball
seems to go much slower
the whole game slows down yeah and it's
really
that equanimity that produces that kind
of a reaction as distinct from
when you have the anxiety there's not
the clarity there's
it's all coming too fast failure is a
part of the learning process
right what's the risk of failure what
you'll be embarrassed or risk affiliate
how do you distinguish failure from
learning uh
in your whole life you know failure
implies that it's stopped that the game
stops right
if it's part of a you're failing and
then you learn
then that learning is part of the moving
forward
right so that is what the process is
like fail
learn move forward and constantly do
that
because you're cutting edge you're going
where people haven't been before
in inventiveness growing up my dad used
to encourage
my brother and me to fail so at the
dinner table he would actually ask us
what did you fail at this week
and if we didn't have something to tell
him he would actually be disappointed
and i can remember coming home from
school and be like dad dad i tried out
for this and i was horrible and he'd be
like way to go
and high-five me and what
it was such a gift what he was doing i
didn't realize that at the time but he
was
redefining failure for me and so failure
became not about the outcome but about
not trying and so
you know the fear of failure as we all
know as entrepreneurs is one of the
greatest fears in life it's one of the
things that stops us in our tracks and
keeps us from trying something
um and so i you know i incorporate that
in my
philosophy at spanx we have we celebrate
failures we talk about them we have oops
meetings where i'll announce the oops
that i have and sometimes we
have fun with it we'll even attach theme
songs to our oops
and we'll play them in front of the
whole company but i think it's just so
important to
try to get the people that you work with
to take risks and to be entrepreneurial
and not
live in a place of i want to protect my
job and feel like i'm not safe if i make
mistakes
how do you turn failure into a plus uh
and
it's true when i was the university of
nebraska
one day i was reading the daily
nebraskan
and it said in room 300 or something
at three o'clock there will be this
panel of three
uh uh professors here at the
university and they're going to award
the nathan gold scholarship i don't know
whether you still you still have that
around
and at the time uh it said it would give
you 500
to go to the graduate school of your
choice i don't know whether it's changed
an amount but
but that that was it so i read this
and i went there to this room at three
o'clock that day or whatever it was
and i walked in the room and there were
the professors and i was the only
student that showed up
i mean it really got to them i mean they
they were stuck
they you know they kept waiting and
looking at their watch and hoping there
would be more candidates
but there no one came in so i won 500
by by default and
those are usually my biggest triumphs
when nobody else shows up
and so here i was i had five hundred
dollars to go
toward any it wasn't it wasn't the limit
as any graduate school
for a master's degree so i applied to
harvard my dad wanted me to
and uh i shortly heard from harvard
and they said go to chicago and meet
this fellow running
that who interviews applicants from the
midwest
so i got on the train and that's what
you did in those days and i
spent about 10 hours on the burlington
going to chicago
then i transferred to another little
interurban train to go up to this
country day school where this fellow was
the headmaster and he was the big
interviewer for harvard
and i got there and after about 10
minutes he
he said better think about something
else that
you know he uh come back later on i was
i was 19 at the time
and uh i looked about 12
you know and and i and i acted about
eight so
it was not a great combination uh but so
he he said forget it
so i spent uh took the little an urban
train back to chicago and i took the
10-hour train back to oman all the time
i think you know what do i tell my
parents you know it's kind of
embarrassing
uh but it was it was the luckiest thing
ever happened to me
i because if i'd gone to harvard i would
have gone to a two-year
business school i i instead applied to
columbia
where i could graduate in one year and
get a master's degree
luckily that by the accident of it and
being in the nebraska national guard
which did not get called up for the
korean war
i missed going in the korean war
i
i got to meet ben graham and which had
an enormous effect on me subsequently
and i probably got my wife that way
because she was going to northwestern
and i was able to put on sort of a full
court press because i got out in one
year
and otherwise she'd she'd have met some
other guy i mean i i got her before the
competition showed up and
uh so it worked out wonderfully it
couldn't have worked out better
and that's been that's been my life
basically i mean it the
things you know you will get some
disappointments you know
uh but the future is what counts
be fun if i knew every decision i was
going to make was going to be perfect it
would not be as much fun be like playing
golf and knowing you're going to hit
a hole in one on every hole you wouldn't
play golf
if every time you got on a tee you just
took a swing and the ball ended up in
the hole
you know be fun for a few days you can
get on tv
but it the game would not be any fun uh
so it's
failure you know and i wouldn't even
consider failures but that they're
mistakes or whatever you want to
call it they're they're part of the game
and
in the end you know you go on and and
we've made plenty of mistakes in
business
we'll make plenty more and then you know
the
babe ruth and you know for a long time
it subsequently got eclipsed by
a few fellows but uh he held the record
for strikeouts you know so the record
for home runs and was highest
baseball player until the modern era
came along
so it's it's part of the game if you
take big swings you know you
you you may you may you're going to miss
sometimes i say
in my relationship with my wife i joke
with my friends
they're like you know describe your
relationship with your wife and i say
often wrong but never in doubt
you know and it's kind of like this half
joke which is really like
you know i'm like blah blah blah blah
and then she has this look that says
and i'm usually wrong and what's great
is
there's this safety where there
aren't a lot of consequences for me
being wrong
silicon valley works because there
aren't consequences for being wrong
in fact there's a celebration of
wrongness more than there is a
celebration of rightness
and i think that that is this one turn
that canada is missing
we somehow and oftentimes too often
co-opt people into a very traditional
mindset of
performance and we measure it in very
typical and predictable ways and as a
result of that
we have these very brittle borders so we
don't allow the outliers
to feel at home here there is no reason
why
some of the companies that get started
in silicon valley should have
there's as much reason in the world that
many of the people because when you look
at those silicon valley companies
they're littered with canadians
i mean littered you know i started
recruiting for martial in 2007
for facebook and it's like we recruit
more people from here
now than any place else but so does
google so does apple so does uber so
does square
why is it the case that these great
companies are built on the backbones of
canadian dna
and we all feel like we needed to leave
in order to express our capability
and so if you take a step back i think
it's in the fundamental celebration of
failure
and creating the boundary conditions
that tell us that it's okay
to try things and not get it right i'm
not afraid to be wrong
like i just think being wrong is
overrated in the north american
philosophy we
we really look there are certain times
where you can't be wrong
if you're a pilot you can't be wrong or
a surgeon i get that or if you're
no it's not true actually surgeons make
mistakes all the time they leave
you know utensils or whatever not
utensils
the things inside the people's bodies i
mean you know
um but i i get how certain professions
need to value
the sort of like the binary distinction
of right and wrong
um but i think for most of us um it's
really sort of like you're either
learning or you're not learning
and i think we right now we create too
much of a like a god complex around
being right
and we don't celebrate enough like the
fun process of iterating
you know and being able to like be in
the grind with people and
like like laugh when things don't work
that it's not like the end of the world
um
so i i think to me like that's probably
the single biggest thing that people
have to
uh get comfortable with which is like
just you're learning you're learning
and you either care about that or you
don't like if you're a good entrepreneur
like we were talking about this in the
green room nobody should grow up to be
an entrepreneur
i'm sorry that's i agree that's
ridiculous
you should grow up to be really angry
about something in your life
that you want to fix or change to make
better
do you know what i'm saying yes
um because then all of a sudden like
you're not going to give up when
something doesn't work
when something is wrong you're just
going to keep working at it because it's
learning but that mindset is only
possible in that context
so i i don't know i just think like
that's a that's a really important thing
to really internalize
what's one of the biggest kind of
signature mistakes that you made
as the head of koch industries well i
look at it
as i i'm i'm i follow the stoic
philosophy that is
uh uh grateful for everything and
entitled to nothing
and i and this is uh consistent with
thomas edison's philosophy you remember
when he
he he had all these he tried all these
things to make a new battery
9 000 things that didn't work and his
friends say well god i'm sorry you had
all this failure she said i haven't had
any failures i've found 9 000 things
that don't work
and i look at at our failures
and that's what's made us successful so
and if you don't if you're not the only
way you can
never make a mistake or never have a
failure
if you don't try anything new and guess
what that means
you have total failure because you're
going out of business
given the the process of creative
destruction that's going on
at at uh light speed pace today
so we're ramping it up so we're we're
driving more creative destruction and
what we
tell every employee whatever you're
doing
that you may be best at the world at
what you're doing our business may be
the leader
and all that it's not good enough if we
don't
improve faster than others
we're going out of business and get
everybody think so everybody comes to
work how
how do i how do i drive
innovation and find new and better ways
to create more value for our customers
and
our other constituencies i've been an
entrepreneur my entire life as far back
as i can remember i would sell baseball
cards
my friends i would buy and sell stamps
and stamp collections
i mean i was i was that kid in the
neighborhood that was always trying to
sell you something
i sold garbage bags door-to-door but
after after actually after i graduated
from college
i was like what what can i do i want to
start my own business i don't want to
get a regular job
um and so somebody came up to me and had
this great idea that i i should try
and they're like look milk's so
expensive
if we sell powdered milk we can sell it
for less
and i'm like that's a great idea so i
started going out there and finding
these powdered milk formulas
and the problem was it didn't taste so
good but i was like
well people don't need good tasty milk
if they save a lot of money
so that business lasted about two weeks
but i learned you know you that you
learn from your failures i mean
like i always tell people it doesn't
matter how many times you fail you just
have to be right
one time then everybody can call you an
overnight success
when you give money how do you measure
success well number one not everything's
going to work quickly so you have to
have some patience number two
if you do something in in the scientific
world and it turns out to be a failure
that in some sense is a success because
you don't have to go down that path
again unfortunately in the world i came
from you're labeled a failure and you've
wasted your money right
that's not the case the way science
works and so uh knowing what you're
doing measuring it
and there are a lot of people around who
are trying to apply metrics in some
cases you can in some cases you just
have to do it on faith
i know down the road this is going to
help and i'm willing to make that bet
and then wait a little while give it the
old college try
if it doesn't work don't be stubborn but
don't walk away from it too quickly
either
many of our parents had stable jobs
throughout their careers but in our
generation we're all a little
entrepreneurial whether we're starting
our own projects or finding our role in
another one
and you know that's great because our
culture of entrepreneurship
is how we create so much progress
an entrepreneurial culture thrives when
it is easy to try
lots of new ideas facebook wasn't the
first thing i built
i also built chat systems and games
study tools and music players and i'm
not alone
jk rowling got rejected 12 times before
she finally wrote and published harry
potter
even beyonce had to make hundreds of
songs to get halo
the greatest successes come from having
the freedom to fail
we have this expression in the valley
called fail fast
really what that is is uh be measuring
the
confidence interval the confidence in
your investment thesis and what you're
doing
and be measuring that in a way that when
you when it begins decreasing and
decreases
substantially like again and again over
time to pivot
to change and you want to be getting as
much early data as much early feedback
it isn't even also data it could be
perspective
to know whether or not your plan is
going to work or not so that you can
adjust early because if you stay oh i
just have my vision
and i'm going to work on this for seven
years you could frequently be nowhere
where is if you had if you had taken
network intelligence
and you had adjusted your plan as you
were going you could end up being very
successful
when one is starting it's hard to say
what whether it'll be successful or not
if it's a assured success then there
would be no risk
if there was no risk everybody would do
it and if everybody was doing it it
wouldn't be unique or innovative
so innovation fundamentally involves
risk-taking
and risk-taking means failure
i like to say my willingness to fail is
what gives me the ability to succeed and
too many people just are not willing to
fail
so they don't try anything new
i like to say you should try
and fail but not fail to try
because the people who fail to try fail
to take risk
fail to do something attempt something
new
are failing before they start they just
don't know it
you cannot achieve success without
failure
some of my biggest successes come from
some of my biggest failures
in the early 90s when my friends were
graduating
from howard
i got fired from that first job that i
got with andre harrell
i know a lot of you know this story but
some of you may not know
how scared i was see i was scared to
death
i didn't have a degree my girlfriend
was eight and a half months pregnant
with my first baby
i bought a brand new house in scarsdale
that i could not afford
so i i found myself sitting alone in my
bedroom
and asking myself the question that
sometimes we all ask each other
what are you gonna do now
what are you gonna do now you should
have kept your mouth shut
and shut up and just did what andre told
you to do
what you wanted to act like you was
making the hit rangers and then
now look at you what are you gonna do
now
so i had two choices
either
i was going to sit in that failure
and give up or i was going to make a
decision to step out of the darkness
you see when you're in that darkness you
want to sit there and wait for the light
to come
when you're in that darkness it feels
uncomfortable
but you can't wait and sit in that
darkness
the only way out is to step forward to
face your fears
to become your own light
[Applause]
i had to make a decision i had to decide
to become my own light i had to believe
in myself
like never before i had to find my
inner power now i'm not gonna lie to you
there's gonna be a lot of times y'all
about to fail i'm still failing every
day
we're we are all a work in progress
and one day you'll be sitting in the
dark
like i was and you're going to be asking
yourself
what am i going to do now
you ask yourself again and slow it down
what
am i going to do now within that moment
i want you to remember the power of you
we saw a fight last night
just goes to show you man you can't take
eight months off eight months of
drinking and
showing off and bragging and running
your mouth
you can still get cracked you gotta
you know huh yeah too many days off man
too many days off
you got to pay the price every day folks
otherwise you lose
period you will get beat you're going to
get beat in the marketplace if you don't
train every day
i'm wearing my cardone university
t-shirt
because if you don't train every day
don't expect to make the sale
if you don't train every day when you
leave here do not expect your people to
follow up if you don't train every day
do not expect your people to answer the
telephone correctly
if you don't train every day do not
expect your people to be motivated
to do the right thing if you don't train
every day if you don't require training
every day if it's not mandatory every
day
you will not get the cash flow you will
get just enough money
to pay the bills and by the way
everybody's got that figured out
everybody on the planet has figured out
how to pay their bills
even people that don't have any money
are figuring out how to eat everybody
agree
so don't be bragging about your bicycles
and your two bmws and your country club
that you paid for
and the roof over your head and you paid
your utilities and your gas
and don't tell me that all somebody else
has got it worse than you
of course somebody else has got it worse
than you i hear this all the time from
people
okay somebody gets whacked they have a
bad situation and they're like but i'm
grateful
well you mean you're grateful man you're
filing bankruptcy i know but i still got
my health
but you don't have your financial health
you shouldn't have gone bankrupt
you should have prepared for it don't
make sense of the failure okay if you're
taking notes
quit making sense of the failures
what were the lessons you learned uh you
know starting from essentially zero
having no money no context
no uh relationships no uh opportunities
in a town that you went to for this show
what did you realize
were the keys to actually making money
even if you didn't have any
well as you see the show you see that i
actually never make any money
right so uh the two girls they they
actually
they follow three of us and the two
girls went out and got a job
in the first week and and i'm not saying
that's right or wrong or
my ways more better or worse but but
they are strategies okay they're
different strategies i was not there to
get a job
or to earn money i was there looking for
one thing
opportunity i never spent time looking
for money ever the entire
uh 90 days okay i'm not looking for
money i was actually looking for
contracts
through the contacts i wasn't looking
for money because i knew the evaluation
of the company
in the last um segment
an evaluator will come in and determine
what my company's worth my new company
right that i created
and at that point i just need to
validate to him
dude my company's worth this based on
that the entire 90 days
i never touched the first hundred they
gave me and this was to prove to people
do you do not need
money like it's just it's not true you
need money you do need contacts
you need people you need people you need
people you need the right people though
the right people that are already in
play okay just because a guy's got money
i remember a billionaire friend of mine
uh you know he could buy
a jet and i said hey bob should i buy a
jet he said you should i shouldn't
meaning grant should because and he's
way wealthier than i am he could have
bought 40 of them
he's like i don't have a place to go in
mine you have you can use yours every
day
so you've got to find somebody that's in
place somebody that not just has money
but somebody that wants
to do more with their money so you'll
notice in the first
uh 10 days i don't spend a hun any money
i don't spend money on shelter
not on food and not on water nothing
then what i do is i
end up accumulating assets and it's
unfortunate that the viewer doesn't see
this
within five days i have two vehicles one
was given to me by discovery
and the other one was a forty thousand
dollar jeep
that i basically used uh from
ryan this guy i met and told him i'm
gonna sell your jeep i'm gonna drive it
around town
and put ten miles a day on it and i'm
gonna sell it well that's a forty three
thousand dollar asset
uh my truck was worth four grand i still
had my hundred dollars i lived in a
forty six thousand dollar rv
that i was trying to sell so yeah uh and
then what what's the other thing i did
and i picked up ten thousand dollars
to do in a 15 partnership in the equity
of the upside of this guy's company
so literally in 10 days i was
accumulating contacts
that could get me equity and the
important part of that story is
man go get you some equity you know
jay-z talks about this
you're getting you know so many of you
young brothers are getting in advance
while i'm picking up the equity the
number one reason
the number one reason you will fail in
this 10x thing
the number one reason businesses fail is
the inability
the inability to sell products in
quantities great enough
and it margins high enough that is the
only reason
you will fail you take too long to go
from the idea
to selling enough products volume at
margins high enough
do that learn to do that
and you can make any dream a reality
okay i want to help the world
this is not taught in schools
[Music]
your parents didn't teach you this
[Applause]
that'd be a disaster dude that'd be
that'd be such a bad that
that's a bad idea i'm sure you've had
some good ideas that's not one of them
[Applause]
i mean i had to talk to you yeah you've
actually lost a lot of credibility with
me right there again
look look i want to help you guys become
super successful i want you to become
partners of mine
i want you to invest in in my real
estate venture
i want everybody here to like be sitting
on the front rows
i want to fly on your jet i want you to
call me up hey grant
grant can i pick you up yeah please do
okay why i got to pay all the time
okay i want i want you speaking on this
stage
i want to showcase your success at
growth conference three
i want to be able to say hey dude was
making 300 grand and he made 3 million
in 10 months
how many ambassadors here today how many
ambassadors
we we just spent the last 60 days with
these people
okay you take very short periods of time
support people in between give them the
right
information and push them we can get
big increases from people but the the
world you live in today the cnbc and the
cnn
and the netflix
[Music]
be happy just be happy
be satisfied with what you have there's
no push man
there's nobody pushing you how about
this you can do more how many of you can
do more
oh my god if that's all you got how many
of you can do more
well god damn if you know you can do
more if you know you can do more
then you have to do more if you know you
can help
if you know you can make a difference if
you don't
you're going to have this freaking big
big hole inside of you no
no amount of money can fill this thing
up
so fill it up i want to help you i want
you to become a partner
i want you to become somebody that we
can work with okay there's eight billion
people on this planet
and there's no shortage of information
how many have heard this before
knowledge is power
then why are so many people suffering
why are so many people suffering no it
ain't stupid man
we have more information available to us
today than at any time in the history of
the world
we got too much information at this
point you got too much information
and not enough action this universe this
planet we live on will not surrender
success to you until
you let it know hey man i'm serious
okay i'm getting what i'm getting today
because the universe whatever this
universe thing is
knows grant cardone is serious i'm gonna
keep showing up
i'm not gonna quit i don't care what
happens
if i don't quit i can't fail okay if i
don't quit
i can't fail if i don't quit i can't
fail okay repeat after me if i don't
quit
i can't fail so you got to drop this
failure thing out of your
your language failures it's a bull code
for you quit
don't be a quitter because if you quit
you will fail
and the reality is you didn't fail you
quit so quit talking about the failure
thing
you got to quit quitting you need to
quit the stuff that's no good for you
and you need to start the stuff that is
good for you
it's going to happen when you leave here
too folks like this planet's got gravity
you all notice that everything
everything that can stop you will
present itself to stop you when you
leave here
to determine how committed are you
you guys got to quit acting like success
is something you don't like
oh yeah that's cool oh so good for him
if he can get it and she can get it
i can get it obsessed with persistence
look it has become acceptable for people
to quit and not see their goals through
this has been happening in the face with
validation and proof and evidence
over history of all the great stories
that each of us know
where persistence is one of the great
characteristics
of success when people quit others
comfort them with condolences
well you tried you did your best it's
all right
it didn't work out we love you just the
way you are just be happy with what you
have
but you don't need to be comforted at
that moment when things don't turn out
right you don't need sympathy and you
don't need comfort
sympathy is not what you need comfort
doesn't pay the bills
you are at the best when you're outside
your comfort zone pushing yourself
and your limits to make the impossible
possible and that can't happen
if you quit only quitting is failure
it is impossible for me to fail
if i refuse to quit see the difference
between success and failure
staying in the game when others throw in
the towel they will quit trust me
most people quit right before the
miracle takes place can you imagine
just moments before it happened look you
just can't quit you have to be the crazy
you got to be the crazy all the greats
or the crazies
look persistence is the characteristic
of legends
do you want to be one or not look when
you persist long after others quit
regardless of the outcome your power
your
confidence your creativity your
leadership your genius
will light up it will automatically
light up i'm telling you i get more
brilliant the more i commit look how
much success
you have plan for you in the future may
very well be determined by this one
single thing how much can you persist
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i want to know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
also if you've already got your
billionaire mindset companion pdf
calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free
in the first line of the description
below and if you're enjoying this
billionaire mindset series give me a
hashtag
billionairemindset in the comments below
so i can celebrate you
if you want to succeed then you need to
adjust how you see failure
failure is going to happen if you look
at the most successful people in the
world
we've studied them they're in the book
they're all over the channel
they failed the most the most successful
person and you look up to that he's like
wow that person is so successful i can't
believe it
they have failed way more than you've
even tried
not everything works out most of the
series that i put out on this channel
don't work out we test
constantly and most of them never go
anywhere they just don't get enough
traction
there's an experiment we failed we move
on to the next one
we have failed more than most people
even try
and that's why we succeed and that's a
consistent habit around people who are
winning
they win because they tried so many
other things and a certain percentage
make their way through
and most people are so afraid to fail
but they don't even try and that's the
biggest failure of all
they're so afraid of it not working out
but not being the big hit
that they just sit on their idea and
then they watch somebody else make
tons of money have a huge impact from it
get it out there may not be the
biggest version of what you're trying to
do but start start small
build momentum see if you still even
like this thing or not see if you can
get some people interested in it or not
and expect to fail failure is not the
enemy failure is normal
failure is welcomed right you're gonna
learn from it you're gonna build on it
you're gonna make it better
if you are not failing if you're winning
every time think about it like if you're
winning every time
everything you touch wins that means
you're playing a tiny game it means
you're racing against three-year-olds
great congratulations you won every
single race because you're running
against three-year-olds
if you want to be the best you want to
have an impact you want to make your
business a success
you want to make money you want to reach
people you're going to have to race
against people
who are a little more skilled and
talented you're going to have to risk
losing you're not going to win every
race but the good news is you don't have
to
you don't have to win every race to
succeed you just have to win one
you can run 100 races you just need to
win one
and then they call you an overnight
success so just adjust your view of
failure
expect things to fail it's not like i'm
cheering for it to fail
but i expect most things that i touch to
fail that's okay
that's normal that's what happens if
you're the person who's just so afraid
to fail that you don't try anything
then you need this video and these kinds
of videos and resources more than
anybody
you need to surround yourself with
people with ideas with resources whether
it's the videos whether it's the book
something else where people are talking
about failure
where you're hanging around successful
ideas because anybody who's saying
not to try something because it may not
work out that's a that's a small
thinking person
if somebody's telling you that like
don't try this because it may not work
out
i would challenge you to look at their
life look at their accomplishments look
at what they're doing and i guarantee
you they're playing small in their life
and that's not something that you want
to emulate
so you need to change your environment
you got to change what you're feeding
into this because the more that you are
accepting that line of thinking the more
you're just going to stay where you are
the more you're never gonna go off and
build this thing the more you're just
gonna
sit on your couch and be a dreamer with
great dreams
with amazing dreams that could have a
huge impact that you never
actually take any action on because
you're too afraid to fail
so if that's you i challenge you so
start getting to that habit
surround yourself with those people you
know you don't have michelle obama in
your life that's okay
the good news is michelle obama is a
pretty public person if this message
resonated with you
you can put in her name as a youtube
alert and get updates every time
she makes a new video if you like my
message you can subscribe to the channel
there's three videos that come out every
day there's enough content there
to start to shift your mindset the key
is making that consistent
the key is consuming that on a daily
basis so that you start to shift and you
start to change because this one video
is not enough
because doing something once is not
enough you are what you consistently do
you are who you consistently hang around
with you are you consistently believe
the key is consistently so what are you
consistently doing
and how is that view of failure
preventing you from doing something
amazing
people don't lean into their dreams
because they're afraid you're afraid of
it not working you're afraid of people
judging you you're afraid of you
being a failure but if you never lean
into your dream
you'll always know that you are capable
of more and regret the fact that you
never had the courage to really take
your shot
so i think we constantly go through this
i i recently went through this
late last year where i got invited to
speak at brendon burchard's event
and a couple thousand people in the room
and up until that point i hadn't done a
big speaking event for a while i'd done
a lot of small
events small small meetups uh even small
speaking engagements
but a couple thousand people i hadn't
done in a while and in my head i was
telling myself
i just want to do a q a q a is the
easiest for me it's the most
fun for me it's the easiest for me all i
have to do is show up
and so i i told them hey what if we just
did a q a
and one of the hosts either brendan or
ethan or or
dean or one of the people there at the
event can interview me
we'll do q a and then we'll open up to
the audience because that's the most fun
knowing that it's helping somebody else
in the audience
and they said we don't really want to do
that format
i was like okay no problem no problem
i'm in i'll speak
and at the two events prior
i did q a i i i brought it up to the
organizer they liked the idea and then
we went to q a and i shining q a and
again i love it
i'm great at it but it also is a easy
crutch for me
because i don't need to prepare for
anything i don't need to have
a you know powerpoint i need to have a
deck i don't even really need to think
that much of what i'm going to say
because it's always bouncing off
whatever the other person wants to talk
about
if i didn't show up though if i didn't
go if i didn't say yes if i sabotaged it
i would have missed out on such an
amazing opportunity right from that one
event where i spoke on brendan's stage a
couple thousand people he then invited
me back to come and speak again
in puerto rico to his big mastermind
group not big people more big people
paid 30 to 50k to be there
and then he invited me to mastermind
with him and dean and his
his homies to help him and his business
and me and mine as well
if i sabotaged myself and said no i only
want to do q a
i wouldn't have gotten that opportunity
and so even though i was
super afraid i said yes even though i
tried to push it towards something else
that was more comfortable for me
i said yes and so it's leaning into the
dream the reality for me was i was just
afraid
people aren't afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of
other people you'll sing in the shower
but you won't sing on the street corner
you'll record a video but you'll never
release it
you'll be your own biggest critic but
you won't at the same time
also be your own biggest fan that needs
to change
starting today so my biggest fear is
disappointing people
i'm terrified of disappointing people
the idea that you would come to my
thought leadership academy
and i would teach you how to win on
social media and get the ideas out of
your head and pay two thousand dollars
to do it
the idea that that you would come and be
disappointed destroys me
and it's led to some positive things in
that i always over deliver i'm always
obsessed i'm always putting so much
value to that even if you only get 10
of the value i'm giving you still more
than made the money that you invested
into any of the stuff that i'm doing
but at the same time it's still this
fear and so i want to attack the fear i
teach myself to attack the fear
and i think you should too even just
attacking it for the sake of attacking
it is good
even if it doesn't lead to a positive
result for your business
it's good because you're building
strength because you're pushing your
comfort zone because you're getting
better because you're growing that's
worth something that's a ton of value
because if you can conquer your fear of
doing this one thing
that translates to every year of your
life if you teach yourself to have more
courage
that translates everywhere so maybe
you're afraid of
if you're on a cruise ship and they they
bring up couples and they do a game show
you're afraid of what might happen on
that game
do it how does that make you a better
entrepreneur it makes you a thousand
times better as an entrepreneur
because that's the same fear that you
face in your business that fear of going
on that game show on the cruise ship
that fear
of taking your phone and recording a
video in public on the street
these fears that seem like nothing they
show up everywhere in your life
they show up everywhere in your business
and so learning to tackle them
especially in low stakes starts building
the muscle
most people don't fail enough most
people are so afraid of a huge fail that
they don't
even try you're afraid of taking a big
bet you're afraid of going into deep
debt
and that fear prevents you from having
the thing that matters the most right
now
in your business momentum you don't need
to fail big but you do
need to start otherwise you will never
build the big business that you're
capable of building
so i'm a big fan of going from idea to
action idea to action idea to action
idea to action get an idea what do you
do you take action
teach yourself train yourself as soon as
you get that idea
don't judge it don't think about it
don't plan and ponder and strategize
because your list of ideas
is a mile long and it's not going to get
any shorter you're a genius you come up
with great ideas you're going to keep
coming with ideas for the rest of your
life
that list of ideas is not going to
shrink
so how do you start moving you take
action i call the two percent difference
instead of planning to get 100 for your
idea what's the two percent difference
that you can just do something about
right now
i think your ideas came to you for a
reason i think it's inspired why are you
thinking about this thing
don't judge the reason just go off and
do something one small conversation
one small action start building momentum
that's the thing that's missing right
now is momentum
you need more momentum you're a genius
you have great ideas
you should be changing the world what's
missing is momentum and i want you to
find it
so quick example when i was on my tour
and we're driving through the desert
through texas
and two people came to my mind one was
my friend mark draker who i'd known for
over a decade and i thought i'm gonna
start a podcast with mark draker
like that's weird why am i thinking
about this why am i thinking about mark
i haven't talked to him for a while i'm
on my tour
well i'm thinking about a podcast i've
been i've been anti podcasts for so long
saying it's not my priority i want to
focus on my youtube channel i want to
build my instagram up i don't care about
a podcast
now for some reason i'm driving through
the desert thinking about my friend mark
and a podcast
what do most people do you judge it you
think about it you strategize
you research is it time for a podcast
how would you make it work
what's the best thing to do just email
mark and say hey mark
what do you think about starting a
podcast together and he said yes
and we started doing a podcast and we
didn't worry what happened the right
gear when did we start the podcast
now like when's our first podcast this
week
let's make it happen and mark's an av
guy
audio visual guy he he has a video
production company
million dollar plus obviously he wants
to use good gear good
sound good good video for the video
version of it
but we can't yet and i'm only a month in
on my tour so what i'm gonna do wait two
months until
no well we'll do it live on instagram
and the audio quality won't be fantastic
and the video quality won't be fantastic
but you know what we're building you
know what's happening
momentum momentum the thing that you're
missing is momentum because you're
trying to make it perfect
because you're gonna wait two months to
start and then by the time two months
happen you won't start
that's the problem and so now that we're
back in toronto we film it and we have
three cameras on me filming it and we've
got high quality
microphones and all of that stuff and
it's a way better product
but we started if we waited two months
it wouldn't have happened
second guy i thought about in the desert
with jeremy jeremy stickney came to my
thought leadership academy late last
year september last year
and why am i thinking about him i don't
know i mean i haven't talked to jeremy
since
this was now it was i met him in
september this was now
what february january
haven't talked to him a couple months
driving through the desert
i think i want to start a youtube
consulting business with jeremy
i get asked all the time for people to
help with their youtube channels i don't
i don't want to be in that business
i don't want to be a consultant but
that's a business
and why am i thinking about jeremy he
was doing something else i don't know
don't judge it don't disrespect it
don't worry about it my next step is i
want to talk to jeremy i'm going to
facebook message him
so nina's sitting next to me so nina we
need to message jeremy stickney and say
jeremy i have an idea for you
and i need to get him on a facebook live
call today
and he was working it's like i need to
get him on the call tell him to take a
break
i need to get him on a call right now
momentum guys
momentum is the thing that's missing
right now it has to happen
right now your ideas matter
don't judge them your ideas are
important
build momentum immediately even though
they don't make sense why am i telling
jeremy to take a break why am i telling
jeremy to call right now this has to
happen
while i'm on this drive right now
because tomorrow i'm going to wake up a
different person by the time i land in
albuquerque
i'm going to be a different person i'm
in the zone right now thinking about it
it has to happen right now you need to
build immediate momentum
this is how you start projects now it
ended up working out with mark
where we're i don't know how many
episodes deep on our podcast jeremy said
yes after that call
and we've been working now he's gotten
his first client and he's helping people
build their youtube channels
it's amazing a lot of the ideas don't
necessarily work out that's okay
you'll get some crazy idea you're still
building some momentum on it and maybe
it doesn't work out maybe mark says no
maybe jeremy says no
maybe we do our first podcast and it
sucks and we both hate it
awesome how are you going to know by
doing
right you're not gonna know by thinking
about it how do i know if i'm gonna like
doing a podcast
i can think and think and think and
think but you won't know until you try
you can't think your way through liking
sushi you have to try it and see
and so this is why i get frustrated
because i think you're a genius
i think you have great ideas i think you
have noble intent i think i think you
should be off making an impact and
making money and changing the world i
think i think you deserve that you
should
but there are dummies that are winning
off of your idea
people who don't have a big mission
people who don't really care about their
customers they're just chasing
an opportunity and they're and they're
making money they are
why what's the difference between them
and you they started
that's the only difference they started
and you're still thinking about it
and so if you go from idea to action
idea to action what's this two percent
difference
the smallest possible way to just build
momentum not strategize not think not
plan
do something email somebody call
somebody
take action man if you guys just did
that
for the next three months your life
would look dramatically different
so how do you make the shift how do you
learn to fail more elegantly how do you
take more risks how do you say yes how
do you take action
i'm going to give you a three-step
process that you can follow step number
one is idea to action
right that two percent difference i want
you to find something today what are you
thinking about
find something today that's been on your
mind and just do something like teach
yourself
i'm the kind of person who takes action
not just watches a video
and gets motivated and inspired but does
something
do the hard thing take some kind of
action even if it doesn't make sense
that's the number one gift that you can
give yourself right now
today after watching this video or even
pausing right now and just sending that
quick email out or making that quick
call
take immediate action right now step
number two is expect to suck
expect to suck one of the big reasons
why people are afraid to fail is because
you're afraid to fail big
don't worry about feeling big feel small
and expect to suck like the first thing
you're gonna do
is going to suck my first podcast sucks
jeremy's first call sucked he's actually
pretty good but it sucked compared to
what he's capable of now like the first
time you try to do anything
you will suck that's okay that's it
doesn't mean you suck as a human
it just means you don't have the skills
yet you don't have the talent yet you
haven't learned the thing yet that's
okay how do you learn
by doing by experimenting
so if you go out and you expect the
first thing to rock then when you do the
first thing and it sucks
you feel depressed you beat up on
yourself
you want to flip it the first time out
expect to fail
fail gloriously it's going to be a total
disaster
that's the best right expect to suck
and what that does is reduces the
pressure if you expect to suck then
there's no pressure then you can have
fun
then you can actually have fun and when
you're having fun
and you're loving it you're going to
create some amazing things so step two
is expect to suck
and then step three is how do that make
you feel
you can win in a lot of different things
there's a there's a million different
ways to win
but you have to be doing something that
you love right that's that's the common
thread between everybody who's had
success they love what they did
and so you're gonna you're gonna try
something new you're gonna go idea to
action you're gonna expect to suck
and then step three is how did it make
you feel did you enjoy it even though
you lost even though you sucked you
didn't get a great
reward you didn't get a great prize
nobody watched your video
you know it was a disaster but did you
like it did you enjoy it
because if you enjoy it it'll make you
want to go back and do it again
and do it again and do it again and do
it again and if you keep going back and
doing things again and again and again
that you enjoy
guess what you get pretty good at it you
learn to bring value to other people
you're on the path to now building a
successful business
and so i did my first podcast with mark
and i loved it it was fun it was a ton
of fun
i gave jeremy a whole bunch of
assignments and homework to do while i
was on the road
and he started doing them i met him once
i got back and we started the business
he got his first clients right i like it
i enjoy working with mark i enjoy
working with jeremy
even though the first interaction the
first episode
the first call was a disaster
and we've gotten a lot better since i
enjoyed it and so
think of these ideas as you're going on
a first date
the goal of the first date is not to get
married
if you try to go from first date to i
need to marry this person
you put so much expectations on it that
you're going to sabotage the date
and when it doesn't go perfectly the
first time out you're going to be
constantly
not even wanting to go on the first date
because you just
you've taught yourself because you've
taught yourself that first dates suck
i never find the right person the goal
of a first date is to go on a second
date
did i like this person enough to go on a
second date with them
if yes then you do it and if it's no
then you go find somebody else
treat your ideas like that too the goal
of testing out your first idea
is not just to make this list of ideas
and an intellectual exercise you can be
proud of yourself on
the goal of doing the first idea is just
to see do i want to do it again do i
want to run the second podcast do i want
to make the second video do you want to
do i want to go to that second event
right you need to try more you need to
be willing to fail more you need to
expect to suck at everything the first
time out
and just pay attention to how it makes
you feel because when you find the thing
that you love doing that you want to go
back to every single day
i promise you you're going to create
something amazing you're going to create
an amazing business you're going to
create a lot of money for yourself and
wealth
you're going to have a huge impact on
the people around you and the world
can't wait to see you get there
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there